so very excited to welcome professor
Nancy kanwisher as our next speaker
she's a founding member of the McGovern
Institute as well as being the Walter a
rosenblith professor of cognitive
neuroscience in brain and cognitive
sciences she obtained her PhD here at
MIT in cognitive psychology she studies
the functional organization of the human
brain and has gained tremendous insight
over the years into and using this
approach as a window into the
architecture of the mind she's played a
central role in the identification of
several dozen regions of the cortex and
humans that are engaged in particular
components of perception and cognition
I'm very intrigued by her talk title as
I am with every talk title so far which
is selective responses to music in the
human brain
[Applause]
thanks sabe and thanks to everyone for
being here that's been lovely to
participate in this celebration of Pat's
life and of the many wonderful
discoveries that have been made by the
govern Institutes and for me personally
it's been just a huge privilege and an
honor to be a member of the McGovern
Institute since it's Senate since it
began a brief apology in advance I'm
coming off a really nasty cold so pardon
the unpleasant noise is coming from my
throat
anyway I will try not to devolve into
coughing Fitz what I want to talk about
today is a seemingly fluffy topic of
music but I want to assert that actually
it's not a fluffy topic it's actually a
really fundamental one for understanding
who we are as human beings and we can
see that in a number of ways
so first music is uniquely and
universally human so it's present in
some form in every human society that's
been studied and it differs
substantially from its closest analogs
and animals music is also extremely
important to us humans and you can see
this to an
all kinds of ways one we have been doing
it for a long time you've probably heard
of the bone flutes that have been found
in caves in Europe that are 40,000 years
old and most people who think about this
think that I actually music goes way
back before that in the form of singing
after all you don't need to make
anything to sing so that probably
happened before the bone flutes music
also arises very early in development in
young infants are extremely interested
in music and they're sensitive to beat
and to melody even melody abstracted
away from absolute pitch something even
songbirds can't do and finally people
spend a lot of money on music forty
three billion in sales last year so
these facts raise a very obvious
question and that is what why do we do
this
why do humans create music and why do
they like it and what is up with that
so thinkers have been puzzling over this
question for a very long time and
famously Darwin said as neither the
enjoyment nor the capacity of producing
musical notes and faculties or of the
least direct use to man in reference to
his ordinary habits of life they must be
ranked among the most mysterious with
which is endowed so indeed it is a huge
puzzle Darwin seems to be assuming here
that music is an evolved capacity that
is something specifically shaped by
natural selection but that's an
important question is it an evolved
capacity and if so what is that function
that was selected for Darwin's answer to
that question speculative but
interesting was it it was for sexual
selection he appears it appears probable
that the progenitors of man either the
males or females are both sexes before
acquiring the power of expressing their
mutual love and articulate language
endeavoured to charm each other with
musical notes and rhythm a note he says
he's speculating that music arose before
language like very very fundamental
we're modern theorists put forth all
kinds of ideas for example the recent
paper argues that music plays a role in
manage
parent-offspring conflict that infant
directed song that is lullaby arose in
an evolutionary arms race between
parents and infants stemming from the
dynamics of conflict and there are many
other such stories but note that these
are just the stories that assume that
music is an evolutionary adaptation
there's another possible argument that
is not an adaptation at all in fact
Steve Pinker wrote quite a while ago
that music is auditory cheesecake an
exquisite collection a confection
crafted to tickle the sensitive spots of
at least six of our mental faculties if
it vanished from our species the rest of
our lifestyle would be virtually
unchanged that may say more about Steve
Pinker than about music I'm not sure
anyway what he's trying to say here is
that it's possible music isn't directly
selected for a natural selection it's an
adaptation itself but some kind of
alternate use of neural machinery that
evolved for some other functions
the most obvious candidates being speech
and language and so now we realize aha
now we have in all this idle speculation
or hot air we have an empirical
hypothesis that we can test so does
music actually recruit neural machinery
for speech and language in it there's
lots of reason to think it does people
have noted so many commonalities between
music and language not only are they
both uniquely and distinctively human
but they both are auditory things that
happen over time and they both have
complex hierarchical structure syntax
and language and some kind of analogue
has been I pathi sized for music and
there been many many studies in the
neuroimaging literature that have
claimed overlap in the brain when you
understand sentences and listen to music
however most of them have been doing
group analyses where you take a bunch of
subjects align their brains and get a
really blurry picture of the average
activation and when you find overlap and
activation in that kind of analysis it's
really not very telling because you
might have no overlap at all in any
individual subject
so really what you need to do is do it
right look at individual subjects and if
Federico has been doing that for a while
and so what she did in a study a few
years ago is first identified language
regions in each subject individually so
you scan them reading sentences and
reading non word strings and you find in
each subject the bits that respond shown
in red here in three different subjects
the bits that respond more when you
understand a sentence than when you read
a bunch of non words such just a
standard way to identify in each subject
the language regions but now that you've
identified them you can say okay how how
much did these guys respond when you
listen to music and so she played things
like this what's not very loud but
anyway more relevant is the scrambled
version it's kind of like a bunch of
cats running along a piano keyboard yes
anyway scrambled music and the finding
is that none of these language regions
respond at all in this contrast in fact
they don't respond above baseline pretty
much when you listen to music compared
to staring at a dot and doing nothing
and conversely we can say what if we use
that same contrast intact versus
scrambled music and we identify regions
in the human brain that respond more and
there's some little bits in the anterior
temporal lobe shown here this is a
dreaded group analysis just to show you
where they are in general but then we
can find those regions in each subject
individually and then ask whether those
regions are engaged when you read a
sentence the opposite of what we did
before and here's the response of those
regions when you read sentences in black
and when you read a bunch of non words
strings and gray and you can see they're
just not interested they don't respond
differentially at all so basically what
we have here is a double dissociation
the bits of brain that responds when you
understand the meaning of the sentence
aren't interested in music and the bits
that respond to music or an interested
in sentence understanding so in answer
to this question like no it's pretty
damn clear that the neural machinery of
language does not overlap with neural
machinery from
at least not the neural machinery for
understanding high-level linguistic
content that is understanding the
meaning of a sentence a very abstract
endeavor which engages regions that are
not tied to a modality the same region
engage whether you hear a sentence or
read the sentence but what about
mechanisms for speech perception that's
an auditory process that's really quite
different you might think that speech
perception this this auditory machinery
that you're all using right now when you
listen to me and when you can make all
these fine grained discriminations of
very subtly different sounds and string
them together to understand what I'm
saying
maybe some of that stuff is involved or
maybe some other part of auditory cortex
when we started thinking about this
actually the organization of auditory
cortex was not well understood so Sam
Norman Haig Nair and Josh McDermitt and
I decided to make a foray into auditory
cortex and we used a method which
several of us have given talks about
before so I'm just going to summarize it
in one slide and this is an unusual
approach in that we didn't start with a
hypothesis and go in and look for a
particular distinctive response
instead we said let's do a data-driven
method let's scan people listening to
lots of different kinds of sounds so we
broadly sampled the kinds of familiar
sounds you hear in everyday life a
person speaking a toilet flushing liquid
pouring a car accelerating the basic
sounds of everyday life we put these on
the web and we asked people how recently
they heard this sound and we took the
top 165 sounds a little two-second sound
clips we then scan people while they
listen to these a hundred and sixty-five
different sounds and we measured the
response of each voxel each little
three-dimensional pixel and in the whole
temporal lobe when people listen to
these sounds and that gave us a matrix
like this so that matrix shows the
response of each voxel each voxel is a
vertical stripe there to each of the
hundred and sixty-five sounds and across
ten subjects we had 10,000 voxels okay
so then we do some math which we will
skip over here it's a variant of
independent
component analysis that basically says
tell me the basic structure in this
matrix factorizes matrix tell me boil it
down to its essence and the nice thing
about this analysis is it made no
assumptions about the data whatsoever
the math didn't even know the labels on
the data didn't know where the voxels
were located or what the category what
the particular sounds were and so it's
really very hypothesis neutral and what
came out of that was that six components
explain 80% of the replicable variance
in that matrix so with just six kinds of
responses we can recreate the pattern of
data we collected so what are those six
responses well four of them respect
reflected more or less anticipated
acoustic properties of sounds things
like selectivity for high frequencies or
low frequencies that's a well-known
property of primary auditory cortex that
it has it's tone of topic it has a
frequency map and we discovered a few
other sort of established not quite
established but not earth-shattering
acoustic properties but two of the
components were nothing of the kind
here's one of them component five this
shows you the magnitude of response of
component five across our 165 sounds and
if I show you the color code for the
basic categories of sounds we can then
average within each category and what
you see is this component responds very
strongly to English speech but also
importantly a response to foreign speech
which our subjects did not understand it
responds intermediately to vocal music
and very low to everything else so this
is a response to speech sounds
importantly not language meaning the the
response is strong even when you have no
idea what's being said you just know
it's speech so so that's a speech
selective component it's not entirely
new a few prior papers had alluded to
this but we have more more stimulus
conditions so the evidence for
selectivity here is stronger than in
prior studies
but the really cool thing was components
X and here's component six if we average
within a category you see that there's a
very strong response to both
instrumental music and vocal music and a
much lower response to everything else
and this really had not been seen before
if we project these components back in
the brain we can see that the speech
selective component lands right here
this is the top of the temporal lobe the
white and black bits are the tonneau
topic maps in primary auditory cortex so
just below primary auditory cortex is
this band of speech selective cortex and
the music components have a little blob
in the front and back of auditory cortex
just above speech selective cortex so
this music selective stuff is really
totally new it shows a double
dissociation of music and speech very
strong one and it tells us that music is
not just co-opting mechanisms we already
have for speech they're completely
different from each other okay so when
you see something that's cool and
surprising your first reaction as a
scientist is really that was my reaction
and so Dana Bollinger and Sam and Josh
and I have been setting out to first see
if we can replicate this result so we
scanned we I mean we I mean Dana scanned
20 new subjects and she also asked while
she was at it whether that music
component isn't a result of musical
training because most people around here
take years of lessons of one kind or
another and so and this this question is
kind of by analogy to a region known as
the visual word form area this little
orange thing on the bottom surface of
the brain which responds strongly and
selectively when you look at words and
letter strings okay and it's known that
that region is a direct result of
explicit training so here's some of our
data here's the response of the visual
word form area in eight-year-olds in
purple is a response to words and you
can see it responds more to words and
lots of other things but in this case we
scanned eight-year-olds who had been
scanned a few years before
barelli's lab and so we aligned the data
and we asked what those very same
regions in each subject we're doing when
the kid was age five before they learned
to read and that very same region was
not selective for words or anything of
the kind
and so that just shows what you might
guess which is you only have this region
after you're taught to read okay
so the question here is whether music is
like that a result of training so to
find out
Dana scanned ten subjects who have no
musical training at all they're hard to
find around here but eight of these ten
never had a one-on-one lesson never
participated in high school band and two
of them had minimal version of that the
least musical training we can find and
otherwise normal people around here ten
were highly trained musicians Berkeley
students and people like that who
practiced many hours a day and have done
so for many many years so first we asked
some of Sam's data this is how we
discover that there were six components
that account for the variance we look at
the variance accounted for as a function
of the number of components we model and
you can see a kind of elbows after six
in Sam's data and here's day it's Dana's
data it also elbows after six so she
also finds that six components account
for eighty percent of the variance but
now what are those components are they
similar to the ones that Sam saw well
yes they are so here's the speech
component here showing the strong
response to the two different kinds of
speech sounds foreign and native and the
similar distribution in the brain to
what I showed you before and here's the
music response component showing a very
strong response to all the different
music conditions including some new ones
that data included in her condition
in a similar brain distribution for that
component as well
so yes it's replicates very strongly in
the new set of subjects but what about
this difference what about the subject
groups do we see this even in the
subjects with no explicit musical
training at all yes we do if you do the
analysis on just those ten subjects you
see a very nice music
music selective component shown right
there and it's not too different from
the music selective component you get in
the highly trained musicians so that
says that the music component is present
in people with no explicit music
training now notice I say I didn't say
this means no musical experience it'd be
virtually impossible to find people with
no musical experience who had normal
hearing so we're just saying here no
explicit training I do think that there
may be a difference between the two
groups we're still analyzing the data
every which way and it seems that you
can sort of see a hint of it here the
that component may be a bit more
selective in the highly trained
musicians but the point for now is that
it's present in both okay so this has
been a bit of shaggy-dog story so let me
remind you where we've been we said that
music perception does not engage
cortical regions specialized for
language understanding and vice versa
that data-driven methods discover a
strikingly music specific component in
human auditory cortex that music
component doesn't respond to speech and
vice versa and it's present in people
with no explicit musical training so
it's not like the visual word form area
in requirement for explicit training
though it's an open question whether it
might be like the visual word form area
in requiring some experience some
exposure to music so this is all nice
but what if what is this music component
business anyway that's kind of abstract
and inferred we sort of have been
assuming that it refers to a population
of neurons that have that response
profile but so far we've inferred it
mathematically we haven't been able to
see it directly and in fact when you
look directly you do not see it very
strongly presumably because these neural
populations cohabit with other neural
populations within voxels which is how
the math isn't able to pull them out but
for somebody like me I like to see it in
the raw data so can we do that so we
figured that perhaps with a higher
resolution method we might be able to
see it
and the higher resolution method we used
was intracranial recordings from
electrodes directly on the surface of
the human brain and one has this
opportunity very rarely in the in the
case of neurosurgery patients who have
to have craniotomies for neurosurgery
and very often the neurosurgeons will
decide to put an array of electrodes
right on the surface of the brain in
order to map out the focus of the
epilepsy and also to map out function so
they can plan their surgical route and
when these patients are exceedingly kind
they say yes they'll be happy to listen
to our silly stimuli while we record
from their brains and we're very
grateful for that when they do and so
this took about four years to collect
data because it's very rare to find
these people so I'm going to show you
data from 13 neurosurgery patients with
arrays of electrodes over the temporal
lobe over the superior temporal gyrus so
here are the 13 subjects showing you
where the electrodes were located the
270 one of those electrodes responded
reliably to sound that is when we played
the that set of 165 sounds and we looked
for a correlation across split halves of
the data showing that the pattern of
response across those sounds was
replicable across repeated tests those
are the electrodes in red the ones that
we test further and so we measure the
high gamma response which is a proxy for
firing rate to those 165 sounds in each
of these electrodes when we do that we
find three different kinds of electrode
responses and I'll be showing your data
showing you those data in a second but I
want to note for the connoisseurs that
the these electrodes were chosen based
on one set of data and the data I'm
showing you was an independent set of
data so we're not double dipping can't
do that
okay here's an example of the first kind
of electrode so what you're seeing this
is this is a single electrode here time
is going from left to right and these
are the hundred and sixty-five sounds
vertically so across each row is a
magnitude of response and so you see a
band
of responses right here and if you look
at the labels out here you see oh that's
native speech and foreign speech and a
little bit of music with vocals so and
here's the type because this is
inter-cranial recording we now have nice
time information and we can resolve the
time response here and you see that the
bottom so this is a speech selective
electrode we found 192 of these this is
very nice they've been characterized
before and but it's it's it's nice in
fact thrilling to see them even though
they've been reported before because
they're so damn selective and so
particular but the real prize in this
study was electrodes like this one over
on the left and if you look at where all
the strong responses are which you can
see in a histogram on the right all the
strong responses are from music
instrumental and vocal music right there
and so if you look you can see well
there's a couple sounds down here that
produced a strong response what are
those well if you look at what those are
they're whistling humming the computer
jingle the thing that goes dead uh right
in the ringtone the most common ringtone
on a cell phone all of which were
labeled as not music by our subjects but
which we could give pass and construe as
not really evidence against the music
story here's the time course of that
response a very strong selective
response and it kicks in pretty fast
after stimulus onset okay and there
wasn't just one music cycles elective
elector there were fourteen of these
here are five of them and you can see a
similar pattern of music selectivity and
a variety of different kinds of time
courses excuse me that's fine
it's just what it is yeah yeah yeah
thank you so what does this mean this
means that music selectivity is for real
it's not just some thing that emerged
from the math it's actually there in the
data we can see it in the raw raw gamma
responses of individual electrodes which
you can't see with functional MRI this
also validates that method that Sam used
in a really nice way but beyond just
validating the exist
students of selectivity for music we
found a real surprise that we didn't
anticipate at all and that is that in
addition to speech and music selective
responses we also found song selective
responses electrodes that respond not
just selectively to music but
selectively to vocal music we didn't
predict this at all here's one right
here you can see it with this band of
response to vocal music shown in pink
years of vocal music very strong
response and again it wasn't just one
there were eight electrodes that showed
here along the bottom here the
selectivity for vocal music and that was
pretty astonishing further the
selectivity for vocal music can't be
accounted for as just a linear sum of
responses to speech and responses to
instrumental music it's super additive
and if you do the careful math we can
show that it's significantly higher than
the sum of those two so it's its own
special thing so an important question I
haven't been tracking time am I almost
out or I haven't okay good okay so I'm
so an important question I haven't
really grappled with yet is whether
these responses can be accounted for in
terms of acoustic properties it seems
unlikely because of the just sheer
heterogeneity of the music samples
nonetheless we need to take this
seriously and luckily I have
collaborators who invented a great
method for doing this so in a paper that
Sam and Josh published just a few months
ago they developed a really wonderful
method where the idea is you take your
original sound stimulus and then with a
bunch of fancy algorithms we'll leave
out you generate an alternate paired
version of it that's kind of matched for
acoustic properties in terms of a
standard model of primary auditory
cortex that's a bank of linear spectra
temple filters and so you make that
model match stimulus and when they do
that you can see that here's a
spectrogram with frequency on the y-axis
and time on the x-axis of a woman
speaking here and here's the model match
sound you can see that it's really
matched this
- Graham very nicely and yet this is all
their date I'm just using their method I
don't want to get credit first I don't
deserve but just to show you how awesome
this method is even though these
spectrograms look so similar they sound
very different so here's the original
sound offers a time warp let me do it
again
is that art offers a time warp okay just
a little sample of speech here's a model
match version you can sort of tell it's
speech but you certainly can't tell this
being said and it's not right at all
let's listen to the violin okay here's a
model match version it sounds like a
bunch of sea lions okay so indeed in in
beautiful studies that Sam and Josh and
Alex Cal have done when you scan
subjects listening to these you find
that primary auditory cortex responds
exactly the same to the original and the
model match version right but higher
level cortex does not okay so so then we
can use we we play these sounds to the
patients who have the inter-cranial
electrodes and we can ask whether the
acoustics can account for it and so
here's how to look at this so here is
two different electrodes that respond
excuse me selectively to music both
instrumental in blue and vocal music in
pink and so this shows you test-retest
reliability so the x-axis is each dot is
a different sound x-axis is one
presentation and the y-axis is another
and you can see it's highly replicable
that these music and and vocal music
selective responses replicate across
repeated tests in both of these
electrodes but what I'm going to show
you next is a similar graph where one
where the y-axis is now showing you the
response to the synthetic version and
you can see in this case that all of
those responses drop in other words you
don't get the same response in a music
selective electrode when you show them
when you play the model match version
even though acoustically it's tightly
matched okay so that shows that it's not
the acoustics that are driving the music
selectively
response and when you do that with the
song selective electrodes here's just
showing you test retest reliability of
two of the song selective electrodes and
here's what you see with a model match
thing again the responses to the model
match versions drop a great deal showing
you that the acoustics alone are not
driving this okay so so no acoustic scan
acoustic low-level acoustic properties
can't account for these selectivities
okay so to conclude these are the points
I did in the interim summary I'm not
going to repeat them the new points
since then are that the music elective
component inferred from functional MRI
has now been validated by direct
recording from the surface of the human
brain no math no nothing second we find
a new neural selectivity for vocal music
these cell activities can't be accounted
for by acoustic properties and so that's
where we are right now and I think
that's cool and awesome but it raises a
huge number of questions I'm sure
they're many of these are already in
your own heads the ones that are most
urgent for us are to figure out what it
is about music that's driving these
responses is that rhythms is it melodies
is it something simpler like the
presence of a note or an interval or a
beat yeah
further we want to know how do you
actually code for a piece of music and a
bunch of neurons right so far we've
discovered two populations of neurons
that surely is not enough what is the
actual neural code for music third how
do song and music selectivity arise over
development are they present at birth do
they arise soon thereafter do they arise
much later unlike the visual word form
area whoops
and of course the question I started
with how much of this if any is a
product of natural selection and I'll
stop there and take questions
[Applause]
questions for Nancy I'm trying hard but
Nancy you your measurement was high
gamma have you looked at other
frequencies is it only a great question
we've only looked at the high gamma so
far typically when you see this kind of
selective response for language stuff
which we've published a couple years ago
and for you know face and color
preferring regions in the ventral
pathway you see it the the primarily in
high gamma and here just a fine and
that's that's the standard finding of
people who are doing intracranial
recording studies right and when when
people have looked other studies not
mine have looked at these kinds of
recording where you also have the
opportunity to measure it unit activity
and the high gamma is most strongly
correlated with firing rates and have
you ever seen inhibition of one
component versus excitation of another
sorry do you mean do we ever see like a
negative response to some of the stimuli
yeah that's a really important question
I skipped over a lot of the details on
the the component method but because
that matrix factorizing a matrix is an
ill-posed problem so you need to make
some assumptions and one of the
assumptions we made with the functional
MRI stuff which you can test
independently so it's not like
completely on thin ice but one of the
assumptions was non negative responses
and in fact that really does fit the
data pretty well with inter-cranial data
it's also very clearly non negative so
yeah congratulations
absolutely fascinating talk I want to go
back to that evolutionary question that
you started attending with just because
the areas are non-overlapping today is
that evidence that he did not arise as a
single area any particular Lucian airily
one could paint a very nice picture of
sexual selection for dance and movement
coordination which are indicative of
being able to hunt being able to do all
kinds of other things which Allah
eventually becomes a sexually selected
trade by itself which then leads to
drumming dancing you know vocalization
and ultimately you know language so my
question is are there other examples of
areas that in primates for example are
combined but then have separated away in
the human brain that would suggest that
perhaps similar things may have been
involved here and early in the evolution
you know that that theory may not
actually be disprovable with modern-day
data yeah it's a super interesting
question of course it's possible that
they used to overlap there used to be
one function and it differentiated and
how we would ever get evidence for that
I have no idea
as for the primate data I can't wait to
look at data like this in macaques my
strong hypothesis is we won't see
anything like the speech or music
selective responses I certainly hope we
won't if we do then our interpretation
just isn't right it's like some other
thing right we have done with functional
MRI this is mostly bevel Conway and Sam
Norman Hagler I was just along for the
ride what I think is a super interesting
study in macaques so a whole other part
of this work that I didn't talk about is
separate from the music selective
responses Sam and Josh and I had
originally reported pitch selective
responses and those are different from
the music selective responses they're
dissociable in the brain and in monkeys
you pretty much don't see the pitch
selective response and in fact I would
go further to say that I think all of
auditory cortex is just going to be
found ly different in mechanics unlike
visual cortex which is extremely
homologous between humans and mechanics
I think you know we use vision in very
similar ways to monkeys but we use
audition in two very different ways
namely for speech and music wouldn't
that be fun I've thought a lot about it
but I you know I should talk to Josh
about this every time I think about that
I just think like the ethics of bringing
some of those people appear to scan them
it's really dicey I don't know but boy
mmm that's hard - yes it's it's it's not
easy but I agree it's a super
interesting question
[Applause]